this is dumbo brooklyn in the opening
scene of bridge of spies
and this is what that same block
actually looks like today to make this
scene convincingly look like 1957 every
detail in this street had to be changed
right down to the font on the signs
this was all rina d'angelo's job an
oscar-nominated set decorator who's
worked on period pieces like the french
dispatch west side story the post and
mad men here's a newsstand that's in
every movie every single decorator in
new york has probably used it about 10
times
rena took us through eclectic encore
props in nyc to show us how she turned a
modern new york city street into a 1950s
time capsule
when a location is scouted the first
order of business is hiding things that
don't belong in the era that starts with
taking down security cameras and
swapping all the cars in the streets for
vintage ones with period license plates
one of the most important details to
swap is any and all signage and knowing
what signs to put up means knowing your
history they used to paint
advertisements on benches in the 20s 30s
40s 50s these are great i would put
these in a smoke shop window this big
tire sign used in bridge of spies helped
make dumbo look properly industrial for
the 50s as opposed to its current look
of high-rise apartment buildings a lot
of neighborhoods were also historically
defined by their communities so you'd
need cultural signifiers like these
signs in hebrew or specific food
advertisements i think i used murphy and
after consulted fish and root of spies
when they're hand-painted that makes
them look older because they haven't
been printed they're not mass produced
small details can make all the
difference
this raised text means it's probably
from the 50s or 60s while the flat text
on these means they were produced a bit
later since most cities stopped
embossing road signs in the 70s and 80s
the font is also a giveaway that
spitting sign looks older than this hair
parlor sign because that typeface has
been around since the 19th century
whereas this category of sans serifs was
more popular in the 80s besides font and
embossing the main thing that set
decorators look at when deciding what
fits into their era is materials this
means knowing what signs were made from
in previous decades
metal
probably from the 20s or 30s because
it's cast
iron as opposed to the plastics used in
more recent decades which made signs
lighter
signs however can only do so much
some contemporary giveaways are
literally bolted into the ground so rena
will cover those using hollow crates and
barrels
old telephone booths can visually block
other modern features this one would fit
right in on a manhattan street corner
from the mid 50s to the late 70s rina
can tell these payphones are from the
50s based on the width and style of the
dial the plastic dial and push button
came later in the 70s and 80s
strategically placed kiosks can also
hide larger giveaways like modern
traffic lights or street lamps she made
six of these more contemporary looking
newsstands for the 70s setting of a post
for a 50s movie she'd take this sort of
newsstand and fill it with magazines
newspapers signs and products all
specific to the decade luckily eclectic
has a ton of those and it's all real
packaging all this stuff besides getting
period products from prop houses like
this one set decorators will scour the
basements of local grocery stores where
shopkeepers often keep surplus products
from decades ago stuff that's good for a
hardware store a beauty parlor
according to rina the key to making
storefronts look real is the quantity of
the products she'll sometimes scan this
packaging print copies of it and use it
to wrap rows and rows of empty boxes
set decorators also do a lot of research
into the consumer culture of the era
especially for a 50s piece since
consumer goods had a lot of influence on
the decade's imagery they need to know
what people were buying and selling and
what kinds of services were offered on
every block there was always a shoe
repair shop because people didn't just
go buy new shoes when their shoes wore
out they would go and get them fixed so
on every single street there's always a
shoe repair guy
new tech like televisions were also
often displayed in windows this is
perfect for an electronics store for the
50s you'd want this kind of tv with the
rabbit ears or any of these other boxy
looking ones this is definitely 50s this
is definitely 50s this is
early 50s she used radios like this for
the 50s setting of french dispatch
even clothing stores had specific models
for specific eras i would put those in a
like a ladies clothing store for the 50
mannequins that filled the front of
gimbal's department store and west side
story rina found vintage mannequin heads
which for females were rounder and had
less makeup compared to later decades
see the difference in the faces they
just have a different structure and the
hair is molded i would use this in a
movie from the 50s male mannequins in
the 50s looked much skinnier and less
muscular than they do today so she
modeled the men's bodies off teenage boy
mannequins
another element custom-made for west
side story was less glamorous so this is
a more contemporary city street garbage
can which we need to get rid of these
older wire cans are what would be on the
street in the 50s and the 60s this one
isn't that old but we've made it look
old
by spraying it down with paint on west
side story i had about 400 of these
because everywhere we went they wanted
garbage everywhere
but some details are harder to replace
like lamp posts productions could simply
replace lamp posts digitally in post but
if you want that look on set you have to
have these wraps you see these back here
those are fake wraps so that you can
wrap a
contemporary
light pose to turn it into one of these
without bringing one of these 70 million
pound ones out designers might also swap
out the light bulbs like in joker gotham
in 1981 would have had sodium vapor
street lamps which gave off a sort of
icky orange glow so the team swapped out
all the modern led bulbs for the old
sodium vapor kind just to get the right
lighting
it's those kinds of fine distinction
that can make or break a period scene
and with all these details it can take
days or even weeks of street dressing to
film just a few minutes of screen time
that's what it takes to create a time
warp in the middle of a bustling modern
city
we'll make
200 newspapers and we'll give props 10
so that they have them for people to be
reading or if there's 100 people reading
and props will make 100. and on the post
it was just
piles and piles of newspapers